in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape just how
dangerous are painkillers we're going to
try to get to the bottom of it with our
guest today dr. Michelle Schafer from
bloomin hello dr. Schafer welcome to the
show so when is it ok for patients to
simply take a pain medication pill or
when do they need to see a doctor what
is important to mention is that of
course pain is an alarm signal for the
body so something is not correct and
this list needs to be find out however
when we have like a very simple
situation for example we have a not so
serious injury when we are doing sport
for example or we have to hang over last
night then we know it's nothing serious
so it's okay when we take one or two
days pain medication however after three
days I think it is very highly
recommended that we will look for a
doctor that will help us and that tries
to find out more what is behind this
pain and if the cause of the pain is
unknown patient should go straight away
to see the doctor yes of course yeah
when suddenly with the pain comes out of
situation somebody has no idea why this
is they should immediately go to the
doctor yes absolutely when it comes to
pain medication one of the most used
drugs on the world i think is
paracetamol yes there's a dangerous drug
to take because it causes some liver
damages yes one has to really look out
for this I mean it is broadly used even
for children because it's very effective
in pain treatment but also against fever
however we have to really we have to
really see that we don't come over a
maximum recommended dose because the
twofold higher dose when we use this we
are we already have the problem of liver
damage so it's a problem about the
dosage so if you stay at a certain
amount of milligrams of the stretch it's
safe but if you use more than
take one pill or so what's the daily
recommended dose photo adults so I mean
you can say maximum should be four grams
so you take one gram four times a day
and in between six to eight hours mm-hmm
one of the other big pain medications is
aspirin so what are the problems about
aspirin yes Ben is quite effective
however it has serious problems
concerning gastritis for example so it's
not so well tolerated by the stomach and
therefore you know one has to kill look
out specifically older patients and
people who have already problems with
their stomach and what about internal
bleeding I mean aspirin makes the blood
thinner one says so can I go to the
dentist for instance get some some tooth
work done or is it dangerous for me to
bleed I mean many many patients that
have low dose aspirin one of four pain
but for cardiovascular problems so for
them I think it's okay if you go to
dentist and have some kind of
intervention however if you have higher
doses for example patients who have
rheumatoid arthritis or so then they
come into problems and exactly i mean
the effect of a sprain is a long term
effect so it's not just the time the
drug is effective it it lasts for
several days four to five days that you
have problems with bleeding is what
about diclofenac and ibuprofen strong
painkillers or more mild pain killers
amazing diclofenac is is a very very
potent potent painkiller and however it
has also problems with gastritis and
whereas i were proven is much more
tolerated it has a problems with
gastritis but much less than diclofenac
you can you get addicted to diclofenac
what I propose I mean not in terms that
you really get addicted some people take
it regularly because they think this is
very this is not a problem it did it
just doesn't have any risks and but if
they cannot be addicted like for example
opiate drugs and maybe that's the key in
pain prevention or treatment getting
active so what do you suggest pay
asians want to get active I think
patients are very grateful if you let
them take control however you have to
advise them what is best for them and it
depends on the situation for example if
you're under a lot of stress you have
maybe something called tension-type
headache it's much better that you go
into like relaxation exercises however
when you have other diseases like
osteoarthritis for example it's much
better to do maybe only call this cause
it'll be physical items yeah yeah just
to get into movement and perhaps this
may just decrease the pain pink has a
habit to stick around a while so even if
the disease underlying the pain is gone
paint sometimes just stays around which
is called a pain memory yes so can you
do anything about the pain memory I mean
these are processes is like a circuit
that we just comes around around inside
rolls around in the end and get stronger
and stronger and it's very hard to
reverse these processes and you can do a
different kind of approaches however
it's very hard to go back to the to this
situation just before the pain started
oh really so which patients are prone to
getting a pain memory effect is it just
with if the pain gets very severe then
the body remembers the pain or other
some types of patients are very prone to
us I mean there's some Sun page for
example of patients we have an
amputation there they're prone to these
kind of things because it's very hard to
treat the pain and the problem often is
that patients too late come to paint
specialist for example or to pain
therapy so they try on their own for a
couple of months and maybe years and and
then it's often too late so the whole
process of Korra fication has already
occurred and what do you do against this
memory effect I mean yoga you can do a
treatment drug treatment of course but I
mean the chronic process also comprises
other factors I mean of course you you
will run into social problems into
problems at work you have psychological
problems so all these factors more and
more influence your chronic pain and
therefore you have to deal with all
these factors
and not with just with one factor and
you just treat with Chris drugs that
this would not be effective so it's not
just one single disease there are
multiple factors like what about fear
and depression yes of course I mean this
is also very strong amplifier of pain
and we have to deal with it and if we
see patient that did suffer under this
we have a antidepressant medication for
them and it's very good also that
sometimes they have an effect that they
inhibit also the pain is also they're
not just for the depression they also
effective for the pain treatment so not
just for the mood but for the physical
pain the patient experiences yeah if a
patient tells you no I don't want to
take any drugs I don't want to take any
medication what do you suggest for
alternative medical things you can do
mm-hmm I mean there are many many
different kinds as I already mentioned
physical therapy is very good especially
you know we have the most patients have
a low back pain for example and the
medication only helps them to bridge a
certain period of time however they have
to use this time to get more into
physical exercise to make them muscles
stronger so that the back is more
relaxed and that they have less problems
right thank you dr. Schafer thanks for
being in the studio Thank you Thank